Hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel. Uh for those of you who are new
here, my name is Jordan. I'm a Google
software engineer and uh in today's
video I will be beginning my refactored
systems design interview series. So uh I
am absolutely a hypocrite for this in
the sense that I said I didn't want to
make redundant content on my channel. Uh
but at the same time um one of the
biggest pieces of feedback that I
received in my last series was that even
though the content was very rich uh I
often didn't give a lot of visual aid
and uh trust me you know I understand
that visual aid is very important you
know for example try you know doing your
thing without hub or something it would
be real tough so with all these things
in mind um you know I've acquired an
iPad I don't really know how to use it
very well my drawing skills are very bad
and my hands are shaky but uh you know
worse Worst comes to worse, the iPad is
going to make certain parts of my life a
lot easier. And uh yeah, my ultimate
goal is to make content on this channel
that is pretty much as good as all those
paid courses from these grifting tech
YouTubers. Uh with the exception that it
is completely free. In fact, I hope to
make it better because uh yeah, you
know, I'm just going to try and do a
really really thorough deep dive on
everything. And unlike my last series
that I kind of made, I'm hoping to even
do smaller chunks per video for a couple
of reasons. One is that it's more
digestible and the other reason is that
I'm a lazy [__] and I don't like editing
that much. And so I figure that, you
know, it's a win-win for the both of us
if this series takes a little bit longer
by doing less per video. So with that
all being said, if you're new here or if
you're new to systems design in general,
I think this series will be super useful
for you. It really does cover a lot. So,
you know, expect to learn a lot and uh
you know, this is a great time to start
learning because the economy is in a
downturn at the moment, but in 6 months
to a year when this series is finished,
you know, jobs are probably going to be
pretty hot again and uh you're going to
want to get a refresh on that RSU price.
So, all those things being considered,
uh let's jump into it. we can go ahead
and do a little example of what systems
design kind of means or is or the
considerations that you might have on
the iPad and I will do my best to make
it understandable for all of you. Uh
have a happy new year and let's get into
it. All right, let's go ahead and get
into this. So to kind of frame the
systems design interview as a problem,
it's basically something like this.
You're a website. You are perhaps even
just an internal infrastructural service
with a lot of usage, right? So much so
to the point that just storing
everything on one machine is not
sufficient anymore. And so let's give an
example of that. So here I am drawing
myself on screen. As you can see, I've
drawn myself to figure absolutely jacked
and muscular. So this is me and in the
context of a website like a social media
website, let's say Facebook for example,
I am what is known as the client. I make
requests to the servers of the social
media website and in exchange I expect
data. So let's go ahead and show that
tradeoff. Here I am drawing a nice
little arrow and then if we're talking
about Facebook for example, here is the
Facebook application server which will
probably be located in one of their data
centers. So now what I'm asking for from
Facebook is some data. At some point I
probably stored something like a profile
picture there. I stored some information
about myself or my past posts and I want
to get it back from them. If Facebook
didn't store this data in the first
place, how could they possibly leak it?
So, here we go. And we have these
Facebook servers. And so, the question
is now uh kind of one of the ways that I
want to start thinking about these
problems is where do we actually store
the data? So, before we even think of,
you know, what servers we store the data
on, let's think about what hardware we
store the data on. So when it comes to
uh data in general and computers, there
are two basic places that you can put
it. And one is RAM. You know, it looks
like a little long rectangular
skinny dick chip. And that is good for
random access or basically it's short
for random access memory, but it's good
for temporary storage of data.
You know, that's where we do our
computations when we're coding. If
you're writing like a for loop, you're
adding a couple numbers. Uh technically,
you know, a lot of that's going on in
CPU registers, but eventually it's going
to get stored uh with the variables and
RAM. And in addition to that, we have
our HDD or our hard drive. And so this
is you, I'm sure you've seen this
before, looks almost like an iPad, but
with a nice little skinny metal disc in
the middle and then this kind of pointer
which points to a specific part of the
disc. Again, pardon my bad drawing
skills. And the good thing about hard
drives is that can actually permanently
store data at least in the sense that
the hard drive itself is not broken or
you know other extenduating
circumstances. So when we are actually
going to store data for a company like
Facebook, we want to obviously put that
on the hard drive. Why? Because servers
can shut down at any given time. You
know, maybe someone unplugs the power
and if that were to happen, we don't
want to lose the data. Of course, you
know, hard drives can be broken too and
we have to think about more than that.
But uh at least for now, let's just
think we're storing our data on this
hard drive. And that's going to be a
little bit slower than RAM, but we'll
touch upon this in future episodes. This
is mainly just for an introduction. So
the next question is what computer do we
actually put uh this data on? Every
computer has a hard drive, but which
computer is the one actually holding the
data? Should it be the Facebook
application server? Well, actually the
answer is probably not. And why is this?
Well, for starters, the Facebook
application server is not just talking
to me. it's talking to a bunch of other
people right here are all these other
betas throughout the world. Even though
I'm the alpha, unfortunately, I have to
contact the same servers as them. And so
eventually there going to be so many
people that just one application server
to talk to all these people isn't going
to be enough. I'm actually going to need
more. And so, you know, we've got all
these other servers. And if we were to
actually store, you know, my specific
profile data on the original server, now
that's going to be a problem because
when these guys go ahead and contact
other servers, they're not actually
going to be able to see their data.
They're not going to have access to it.
And so, in this sense, we want our data
itself to be scalable in a way that is
separate from our application servers.
the application servers or at least the
user requests to application servers
typically becomes a bottleneck to the
performance of our website before the
actual accessing of the data does. Uh
typically that's because there's things
like caching where we can temporarily
store some of the data on these servers
and you know that that makes things
easier. But again this is all stuff
we're going to get into later. So what
we really want to be doing instead is
basically having one other computer in
the background. You'll see I'll draw it
as this cylinder here. And this is what
I'll call a database.
The database is only responsible for
being basically the sole source of truth
of all of that profile data, post
history, all of these things. And now
application servers can go ahead and
just ask the database for specific data
about profiles, my users, all my
Facebook history, etc., etc., etc.
This is completely oversimplified,
right? The truth of the matter is when
you have so many users, even one
database isn't going to be enough,
right? We could make the computer that
the database is located on more
powerful, but eventually even that's not
good enough. There's simply just too
many humans in the world. And so the
main kind of point of systems design is
how can we make the fetching and storing
of this data faster both in reads and
writes and more reliable. What do I mean
by more reliable? I mean fault tolerant.
What if I were to unplug the computer
that the database was on? Now I could
never fetch my post history because all
these application servers would fail to
contact the database. So what that means
is we have to come up with ways to
basically have backups. If there's too
much data for one database, we may have
to actually split the data into multiple
databases and be smart about that. And
again, pretty much all of this just
arises from complications of having tons
and tons of users on these massive
websites.
And so in order to kind of first tackle
the problem of covering all of these
systems design interview tips, I prefer
to kind of start with the inside out in
the sense that I'm going to start from
the database and slowly slowly move
towards kind of the client layer, right?
Going to the application servers,
thinking about caching, things like
that. And if you know what those terms
mean, that's great. If you don't, no
worries. We're going to learn all of
them and it's going to take a while, but
ultimately it will be well worth it. So
guys, thank you for watching the first
episode. I hope that this format of
teaching works well for you in the sense
that I will now mostly be doing a lot of
writing on the iPad. Uh but at the end
of the day, we're all going to learn a
lot. I'm still learning a lot by
teaching this. And uh yeah, let's do our
best. to have a happy new year again.